العربيه العاديه في دورتها ال 32 والتي
تراسها اليوم سيدي صاحب اسم الملكي ولي
العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء الامير محمد بن
سلمان نيابه عن خادم الحرمين الشريفين
حفظهم الله بحضور اشقائه اصحاب الجلاله
فخامه والسمو قاده الدول الاعضاء
حيث ناقش اصحاب الجلاله كذا واضح حيث ناقش
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو ابرز
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه المتعلقه
بالعالم العربي والتي التمس امن الدول
العظاء وصالحها المشتركه واسفر عن القمه
اعلان جده تاكيدا على اهميه تعزيز العمل
العربي المشترك بما يسهم في حشد الطاقات
والقدرات لصناعه مستقبل قائم على الابداع
والابتكار
ان الابداع والابتكار
ومواكب التطورات المختلفه بما يسهم في
تحقيق الامن والاستقرار وتضمن اعلان جده
متابعه التطورات والاحداث الجاريه
في جمهوريه السودان
بما يتطلب من ترسيخ تضامننا وتعزيز
وترابطنا ووحدتنا لتحقيق طموحات وتضرعات
الشعوبنا العربيه ومن هنا فان انا ايضا
نرحب برساله الفخامه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وارساله الرئيس الصيني
الموجهه الى القمه كما اننا استمعنا الى
كلمه فخامه الرئيس الاوكراني الذي حضر
بدعوه من المملكه العربيه السعوديه لهذه
القمه واتقدم جزيل الشكر للجمهوريه
الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه على
مبادلته من جهود كبيره خلال قيادتها
الاعمال الدوره الماضيه الحادي والثلاثين
والتي تتكللت ولله الحمد بالنجاح والان
يسرني ان اعطي الكلمه الاخيره العام
فليتفضل معاليه
شكرا شكرا صاحب السمو
في البدايه
ينبغي ان الانسان يعبر عن عميق الشكر
لخادم الحرمين
الشريفين
ويعبر عن عميق الشكر للاداره المتميزه
لصاحب السمو الملكي محمد الامير محمد بن
سلمان
المملكه
بذلت جهدا طيبا للغايه ووضعت الكثير من
الموارد والامكانيات في خدمه هذه القمه
والحقيقه حققت الهدف المطلوب منها تماما
القمه اتصفت بصفه يعني انا مضى عليها عده
قمم الان هذه ربما القمه السادسه او
السابعه لكن هذه القمه اتصفت
بصفه واضحه للغايه وهو التوافق اللي قبل
القمه وخلال عمليات القمه
في خلاصتها الاجتماعات
كانت اجتماعات سلسه وهادئه
لعل الجميع لاحظها انه القمه ما استرختش
فتره طويله في بحث هذه القرارات ولا
الاجتماع الوزاري ولا حتى اجتماعات
المندوبين
القمه صدر عنها بعض القرارات الهامه
اهمها في تقديري هو القرار الخاص بعوده
سوريا له رمزيه واضحه للغايه
اتصالا بموضوع عوده سوريا
فوضح لي شخصيا ان هناك رغبه وعزم اكيد ان
تكون عوده سوريا بدايه لانخراط عربي اكثر
فاعليه
في حل لازمه السوريه
واستعادت سوريا لدورها الطبيعي في
المنظومه العربيه
وتجاوز الظروف الصعبه التي مرت بهذا البلد
العزيز علينا جميعا نحن العرب
وبالتالي
سوريا تحتاج لمساعده اخواتها
وهي في نفس الوقت
ينبغي ان تتفاعل مع هذه الخطوه التي قامت
بها المجموعه العربيه
الازمات العربيه احتلت مكانا مهما على
اجنده هذه القمه
هناك
شعور واضح انه العرب يرغبون في امتلاك
ناصيه التفاعل والتعامل مع المشكلات
العربيه وعدم تركها اطلاقا
للقوى الاجنبيه او الاقليميه
هناك ايضا احساس
بحاله من الهدوء مع الجوار العربي
ومن يرصد القرارات الصادره عن القمه في
علاقات الجوار العربي مع
دول العربيه يجد ان هناك تهدئه
والقمه والجانب العربي بيطرح التهدئه
وينبغي ان تلتقط الخيط
دولتي تركيا
وايران تحديدا لانه كان هناك قرارات
وتم تهدئه هذه القرارات
اعطاء الفرصه
لدول الجوار لبدء صفحه جديده
القضيه الفلسطينيه كانت على راس النقاشات
ووضحت في كافه
التدخلات والقرارات الصادره عنها وهناك
تمسك
بمبادره السلام العربيه وهناك جاهد
بذلته المملكه منذ سبتمبر الماضي
شاركت في الجامعه العربيه
وذهبنا الى نيويورك وعقدنا اجتماعات مع
المجموعه الاوروبيه مع الدول الدائمه
العضويه في كيفيه الاحتفاء بمبادره السلام
وبمناسبه مرور 20 عاما عليها ثم عدنا مره
اخرى الى بروكسيل وهناك رغبه اكيده في
تنشيط
التحرك في اطار مبادره السلام العربيه
الموضوعات الاقتصاديه
لقيت اهتمام ومن يتابع هذه القرارات يجد
انها فعلا يعني
قرارات الصادره عن القمه انه انه الموضوع
البعد الاقتصادي والاجتماعي بيعظه باهتمام
كبير
في
الخلاصه اود القول ان هناك حيويه وحركيه
جديده في العالم العربي
نتطلع جميعا بان تكون هذه القمه قمه جده
بدايه لان ياخذ العرب امورهم بايديهم
ويتحركوا باراده جماعيه لتسويه الازمات
القائمه في المنطقه العربيه
الحقيقه المنطقه العربيه مرت
ربما عقد كامل
من الصعوبات
وهي في طريقها او امل انها في طريقها الى
الخروج من هذه الصعوبات فكل
الخير وانصح الجميع باعلان بقراءه اعلان
جاده باهتمام لانه من
يطلع على القرار على الاعلان
هيجد
في صدر
الاعلام القضايا الفلسطينيه وده شيء
يعني اللي اعدوا هذا الاعلان كان لديهم
اقتناع كامل به حيويه هذه القضيه خصوصا في
هذا التوقيت تحديدا الذي يضغط الجانب
الاسرائيلي بكل التشدد وبكل العدوانيه
وبكل التطرف على الفلسطينيين شكرا جزيلا
سمو الامير على كل شيء
شكرا معالي الامين العام
وماليه مرتبط برحله
فنحاول اذا امكن ان نختصر قدر المستطاع
لكي لا نخسر وجوده معنا
بعد نعطي السؤال الاول قناه القاهره
الاخباريه
امل الحناوي من القناه القاهره الاخباريه
سؤالي لوزير الخارجيه السعودي سمو الامير
فيصل بن فرحان لماذا اخترتم للقمه عنوان
التجديد والتغيير وايضا هل يمكن ان تكون
الظروف مهيئه انت تستضيف بلد عربي يعني
البرهان وحاماتي على مائده حوار واحده
خلال الفتره القادمه سؤال الاخير لمعالي
السيد احمد ابو الغيط الامين العام
للجماعه العربيه بالنسبه لاوضاع في
السودان كيف ستكون ليتعمل اللجنه الوزاريه
العربيه المكلفه بالحوار مع الاطراف خلال
الفتره القادمه شكرا شكرا جزيلا القمه قمه
جده بالنسبه
الطرفين
بالنسبه ما يحصل في السودان طبعا نعمل في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالتعامل مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حاليا على تهيئه الاجواء للوصول الى هدنه
انسانيه بعد ان صدر اعلان جدا التزامات
بالمبادئ الانسانيه والان نطمح ان نصل
قريبا ان شاء الله الى هذه الهدنه وهذه
الهدنه تؤسس لما ياتي من بعدها من حوار
نامل من خلال الوصول الى حل لهذا النزال
لكن التركيز الان هو على الوصول الى هدنه
انسانيه تتيح للمواطنين السودانيين يعني
التنفس قليلا ويعني ان يصلون الى حاجياتهم
الانسانيه المباشره الوضع في الخرطوم
مناطق اخرى في السودان الحقيقه مؤسف
للغايه ولذلك من المهم ان نصل الان الى
هذه الهدنه ومن هذا المنبر ادعو الجميع
الاطراف في السودان الى التهريب المسؤوليه
والجنوح الى الحوار والابتعاد عن استخدام
السلاح لحل الخلافات لان من يدفع الثمن هو
المواطن السوداني قبل كل شيء
يعني هو
لجنه التواصل او اليه التواصل اجتمعت اول
امس
سمو الامير مع وزير خارجيه مصر مع امين
عام الجامعه العربيه
واستمعنا لتقرير الحياه ممتاز يعني جهد
المملكه السعوديه في
السعي بين الطرفين لتحقيق وقف اطلاق نار
ثم الانتقال الى هدنه مفتوحه ثم بدء البحث
في في صلب التسويه
اتوقع انه تكون لدينا لقاءات اخرى في هذا
الثلاثي
المملكه السعوديه الامانه العامه وجمهوريه
مصر العربيه نامل انه ان الامور تتحرك الى
الى تسويه او تسويه الوضع بشكل ايجابي
المؤسف والمزعج واستشعرت هذا في احاديث
الجميع اليوم
هو
الاسى لشعب السودان لانه الشعب يعاني
وهناك مصالح ضيقه تدفع بمصالحها المستمر
الى صاحبه الشرق الاوسط
مساء الخير عبد الهادي حبتور صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط سؤال سمو الامير تحدثتم عن
المبادرات سوف تعمل عليها المملكه خلال
رئاستها للقمه العربيه
بشان التنميه المستدامه
لو تحدثنا بشكل اكبر عن المبادرات التي
ستركز عليها المملكه السؤال معالي الامين
العام يتعلق هناك توجه عربي
في الفتره الاخيره لحل الخلافات العربيه
داخل البيت العربي هل سنرى دور اكبر
للجامعه العربيه في حل النزاعات في
الملفات او في النزاعات العربيه خلال
الفتره المقبله شكرا جزيلا شكرا والحقيقه
هي نقطه مهمه موضوع المبادرات التي قدمتها
المملكه
تاتي بكثير من عناصرها مستوحاه من
مستهدفات رؤيه 2030 وتركيزها على التنميه
المستدامه من اهم المبادرات اللي طرحناها
مبادره استدامه سلاسل امداد السلع
الغذائيه الغذائيه الاساسيه للدول العربيه
العالم العربي عنده قوه شرائيه هائله
وعنده يعني فرصه كبيره يعني للاستفاده من
هذه القوه الشرائيه لتعزيز استدامه
الامن الغذائي في الموقع السعوديه تعرفون
ان نركز دائما على الانشطه على ان نعالج
التحديات عن طريق فكره اقتصادي حديث عن
نعتمد على استدامه الاقتصاديه وهذا يعني
ان نبني مبادرات
في اساسها مبنيه على تصور استثماري ممكن
ان يحقق عائد من خلال استغلال
سلاسل الامداد بشكل اكثر فاعليه يحقق لنا
فوائد كبيره نستطيع فيها نعزز الامر
الغذاء العربي في ايضا مبادره انشاء
حاويات حاويه فكريه للبحوث والدراسات في
الاستدامه
وهذا نحذف منه ايضا انه يكون الحوار عن
الاستدامه الاقتصاديه في العالم العربي
متبناه داخل العالم العربي ونكون نحن
متصدرون لفهم ما هو في مصلحه اقتصاداتنا
كيف نبني اقتصادات اكثر استدامه وكيف انه
احفز الحوار
الاقتصادي العلمي في هذا الجانب ايضا في
مبادره وهذه مبادره الحيه مهمه جدا مبادره
البحث والتميز في صناعه تحليه المياه
وحلولها كثير من دول العالم العربي تعاني
من شح في مصادر المياه
يعني التقنيات في هذا المجال تتقدم بشكل
سريع وكلما استطعنا ان نت في العالم
العربي لتطوير هذه التقنيات واستثمارها
بشكل الصحيح كل ما استطعنا نعزز الامن
المائي العربي ويعني من المهم ان لا نعتمد
على الاخرين يعني لا نريد ان نستورد كل
تقنياتنا وكل احتياجاتنا فيما يتعلق
بالامن المائي من العالم غربا كان او شرقا
والمملكه تحققت قفزات مهمه في تطوير
منظومه المياه لديها وعندنا تجارب نيره
سواء في التحليه او في حتى ضبط
الهدر المائي نستطيع ان نشاركها مع بقيه
الدول العالم العربي والعالم العربي ايضا
له تجارب ويوجد مراكز علميه فاعله حول
العالم العربي لو استطعنا ان نجيش هذه
الخبرات
ونسخرها لمعالجه هذا التحدي الكبير
سنستطيع ان نكون مركز
العالمي في تطوير التقنيات المتقدمه
لمعالجه موضوع الشرح المياه ايضا لدينا
مبادره تعليم اللغه العربيه الغير
الناطقين بها اللغه العربيه هي ما يجمعنا
وهي
ما يسمعه مننا العالم ونريد ان يسمع ان
العالم بلغتنا لا ان نترجم انفسنا لهم
وهذا له جانب ثقافي له جانب قوه ناعمه
اقتصادي يعني كلما استطعنا ان ننشر اللغه
العربيه حول العالم كل ما استطعنا ان نفتح
افاق جديده للمحتوى العربي المحتوى الفني
والمحتوى الثقافي وهذا ايضا يعني يدعم
وجودنا حول العالم يعني نجد لغات كثيره
منتشره اللغه العربيه يعني في راي
المتواضع هي اجمل اللغات ولذلك تستحق ان
يكون هناك جهد كبير لنشرها حول العالم
هناك ايضا مبادره حول استدامه الاستدامه
الثقافيه وامور اخرى مبادره لكن هذه
المبادرات الحقيقه المهمه التي يعني نعمل
عليها مع الامين
يعني
للرد على مراسل شرق الاوسط يعني طبعا
ينبغي الاعتراف انه
غالبيه المشكلات العربيه او الازمات
العربيه كانت تعالج على مدى العشره اعوامل
الماضيه او اكثر خارج الاطار العربي
وبالكاد كانت المجموعه العربيه او الدول
العربيه تدفع فيه او تشارك فيه
ومع ذلك
يلاحظ انه قرارات اليوم على سبيل المثال
في لجنه من خمس دول خاصه من خمس دول
والامانه العامه خاصه
بسوريا ولجنه اخرى خاصه
بالسودان هناك تفاعل من الجامعه العربيه
مع
الازمه الليبيه في الاطار الدولي وبالتالي
سوف
هذه اللجان سوف تعمل
لدي بعض
المعلومات اللي تؤشر الى انه اللجنه
المعنيه بسوريا سوف تجتمع قريبا
وهناك دعوه
بدا الترويج لها
لعقد هذا الاجتماع بشكل
عاجل
اتصور انه موضوع سوريا سوف يحصل باولويه
والقرار بيتضمن اشاره واضحه
انه انه السعي نحو التسويه تدريجيه
للوضع السوري من خلال خطوه مقابل خطوه هذا
يتطلب نقاش مع
الحكومه السوريه
نعطي المايك سكاي نيوز
السلام عليكم محمد المحمود مسكين يوز
عربيه سؤالي موجه لمعالي الامين حاله
التعافي العربيه التي نشهدها الان
ترى هل ستشكل
ربما عائق في سبيل تطوير العلاقات العربيه
الامريكيه في الشق الاخر ايضا من السؤال
هل هناك جهد
دبلوماسي عربي تخطط له الجامعه العربيه
للقيام به
لتجاوز ازمه عوده العلاقات السوريه
العربيه مع الجانب الامريكي والاوروبي كون
انهم يعني لديهم موقف مغاير من عوده سوريا
الى الحضن العربي
يعني هو الحقيقه سؤال هامه للغايه
انا شخصيا انا شخصيا امين عام للجامعه
العربيه
اتصور انه يجب ان نعمل بمعزل عن
رؤيه القوى الخارجيه لهذه الخطوه تحديدا
خطوه عوده سوريا الى الجامعه العربيه لانه
هذا ايضا امر خاص بالعالم العربي بالدول
العربيه بالشان العربي اذا اذا دوله منشئه
للجامعه العربيه
دوله من السبعه الاصليين
استعادت مقعدها
فهذا شان عربي
نحن اتصور انه علينا ان نسعى لاقناع القوى
الاخرى
بصحه المنهج العربي وانه هذه اراده عربيه
ولا نسعى لصدام او اختلاف مع القوه
الخارجيه هناك
اجتماع قادم
بين المجموعه الاوروبيه والمجموعه العربيه
مقرر له
تاريخ ما في القريب العاجل
اتمنى
ان لا تقرر القوه الرافضه لهذه العوده ان
تقاطع هذا الاجتماع او ان تقول اننا لا
نرغب فيه لانها اذا كان هذا الامر كذلك
دول مجموعات كبيره يعني المجموعه العربيه
22 دوله المجموعه الاوروبيه 27 دوله او 28
دوله يعني سويا بيشكلوا ربع عضويه الامم
المتحده
فنحن نرغب في اقامه العلاقات الطيبه مع
الجميع
وامن ان الجميع
يتفاعل مع هذه الرغبه
نعطي المايك للقناه الاخباريه السوريه
ربى الحاجه للاخباريه السوريه سؤال لمعالي
الوزير بدايه في ظل مناخ دولي بات يتجه
نحو التعدديه القطبيه ويدفع كثير من الدول
للتحرر من ضغط الاملاءات الخارجيه التي
كانت تحد سقف قراراتها وربما خياراتها
سؤال الى اي حد ساعد
التحرر من سطوه الاملاءات الخارجيه هذه
الدول الى
ربما بناء
سياساتها على اساس المصلحه القوميه وليس
على اساس مصلحه الخارج او الاخرين وهل هذا
ما عجل في اعاده لم الشمل العربي
وفك ربما طوق القيود الغربيه
وساعد في ايجاد اليه تفاعليه
يعني الجامعه العربيه ولماذا تمت دعوه الى
الجامعه العربيه او الى هذه القمه هل هناك
من مدلول سياسي ارددت السعوديه سؤال
للامين العام لو سمحت كثير من الشارع
العربي لم يعد يتابع قمم الجامعه العربيه
الاعتبارات كثيره اليوم كيف تعيد اقناع
هذا الشارع بانه الجامعه تغيرت هناك
اطلاقا لسببه لسبب وحيد من سبب وحيد اني
قرات مئات المقالات
ومئات الاراء
والرؤى والاهتمامات العربيه في الاعلام
العربي على مدى الشهر الماضي بشكل يعني
كنت الهس وراء الاعلام الذي اهتم بهذه
الجامعه
وبهذه القمه وبالتالي سيدتي سيدتي هذا
المؤتمر بهذا الحجم بهذا الاهتمام يعكس
اهتمام المجتمع العربي بالجامعه العربيه
ان جي لديك رؤيه اخرى
[تصفيق]
خلاص السؤال انتهى وجاوبت عليه
المايك في قناه الجزيره
يعني انا ببني على اللي قالوا اخوي احمد
اعتقد شكرا
اعتقد الجامعه العربيه مثبته فعاليتها
وتفاعل الدول العربيه مع بعضها وتصديها
لملفاتها
تصديها لمواقفها بشكل مستقل واضح للعلم
واعتقد الطرح
حول يعني تجاذبات او املاءات او كذا هذا
من الماضي وليس اصلا مكانه هنا ولا هو
وقته
المهم ان نركز على الانجاز وراينا في هذه
القمه ان مجموعه الدول العربيه مهتمه
بالانجاز ومهتمه بالنظر الى المستقبل
قناه الجزيره تفضل بدرب عن قناه
فيصل بن فرحان هل من تطور في المباحثات
السودانيه تجري في جولتها الثانيه هنا بين
اطلاق النزاع يمكن الحديث عنه توافق حول
نقاط معين ربما اعلان قريب بهذا الخصوص
شكرا
المحادثات جاريه بالفعل الان
هنا في جده
الجهد متواصل هناك
تقارب نوعا ما لكن من المبكر ان نتكلم عن
انفراجه او عن وصول الى اتفاق
نلمس من الجانبين
استشعار
لخطوره الوضع واستشعار لمعاناه الشعب
السوداني ونامل ان يترجم استشعارهم هذا
لمعاناه الشعب السوداني الى تغريب الحوار
والابتعاد عن القتال وتسخير ما يلزم من
وقف الاطلاق النار وثم حوار سياسي للوصول
الى حلول ترفع عن السودان هذه الازمه
الخانقه
نجي لاحمد موسى رافع ايده احد الاعلاميين
يعني عنده واسطه شو نسوي
مساء الخير سمو الامير معالي الامين العام
اولا كل التحيه للجامعه العربيه وكل
التحيه الاشقاءنا في سوريا نحن جميعا نرحب
بعوده سوريا للجامعه العربيه كنا نطالب
دائما بعوده سوريا للجامعه العربيه ولكن
لا نريد خلافا على الاطلاق الجامعه
العربيه والامين العام للجامعه العربيه
واحد من اهم الدبلوماسيين في العالم
العربي لا يليق ابدا في مؤتمر صحفي عالمي
يتم الحديث بهذه الطريقه مع الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
والجميع ولكن سؤالي ايضا
لسمو الامير ومعالي الامين العام ربما
زياره او الدعوه التي وجهت الى الرئيس
الاوكراني هل معناها ان العالم العربي
اتخذ من مسار الحياد مسار اخر هو الانحياز
الى اوكرانيا على حساب روسيا وماذا عن
علاقتنا مع روسيا وهذا هو سؤال مؤجل اسمه
الامير ومعه الامين العام
شكرا بالتاكيد يعني
دعوتنا
لفقره هي من باب سماع
وجهه نظر جميع الاطراف
واتخذت الدول العربيه منذ بدايه هذه
الازمه موقف الحياد وليس الحياد السلبي بل
الحياد الايجابي كنا منخرطين في
فتح الحوار مع الطرفين املا في ان نستطيع
ان نصل الى سبيل يفتح الباب للحل للحل من
خلال الحوار قناعه كل الدول العربيه ان
هذه الازمه لن تحل الا بالحوار والحوار
بالتاكيد بين طرفي النزاع الرئيسيه
وهو مروءه روسيا واوكرانيا وهذا يستلزم
التواصل مع الجميع والسمع من الجميع
ولا شك اننا حريصون كل الحرص على علاقتنا
معه اوكرانيا كل الدول العربيه تقريبا
لديه علاقات ممتازه مع اوكرانيا تسبق هذه
الازمه كما اننا حريصون مهتمون بالحفاظ
على علاقتنا
روسيا التي ايضا كل اغلب لم يكن كل الدول
العربيه لها علاقات مهمه مع روسيا لكن
الواقع ان هناك ازمه هناك
حرب لا بد ان نجد سبيل لنهائها وهذا لن
يكون الا بالانفتاح على سماع جميع الاطراف
وجميع الاصوات الرئيس الاوكراني اتيحت
الفرصه لمخاطبه الجامعه العربيه هو كان
حريصا الحضور ليسمع منه العرب ونحن كنا
حريصون ان نسمع منه كما اننا حريصون
بالتاكيد ان نسمع من الجميع لان بدون ان
نسمع وجهات النظر لن نستطيع ان نكون
مساهمين فاعلين في ايجاد حل يعني استرعي
انتباه ان منذ بدايه الازمه كان هذا موقف
الجامعه العربيه حتى ان هناك
في فتره قريبه من بعد اندلاع الازمه
يذكرنا ربما الامين العام توجه وفد من عدد
من وزراء الخارجيه العرب للقاء الطرفين
لمحاوله الدفع الى التسويه عبر الحوار
وهذه
تبقى انا لابد من حوار لحل هذه الازمه لان
الازمه لا تؤثر فقط على روسيا واوكرانيا
لكن تؤثر على كل دول العالم بما فيها دول
العالم العربي
يعني هو مثلما قال سمو الامير
الاستماع لوجهات نظر الطرفين
امر امر واضح لدى الجامعه بمعنى
مثلا وزير الخارجيه الروسيه لافروف خطب
مجلس
مجلس الجامعه في في القاهره
مجموعه الوزراء العرب مجموعه لجنه الاتصال
العربيه التقط بلافرو في مره اخرى في
سبتمبر الماضي في نيويورك اللجنه اللي
بيشير لها سمو الامير سافرت الى موسكو في
ابريل
2022 وايضا الى وارسو للقاء مع وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي
استماع لوجهات نظر الطرفين امر ضروري
والدول العربيه زي ما بتحدث تسعى له البحث
عن تسويه وطرح رؤى فلا يمثل اكثر من هذا
سيصلكم الدوره ان شاء الله سؤال الى معالي
الوزير سمو الامير سمعنا مؤخرا انتقادات
امريكيه شديده للدول اللي طبعت مع الحكومه
السوريه
[موسيقى]
وفي هل ستؤثر العقوبات الغربيه المفروض
على سوريا على تدفق الاستثمارات في
المستقبل واعاده البناء شكرا
شكرا جزيلا
حقيقه يعني انا تكلمت منذ فتره
وذكرت ان وجهه نظر المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ويتضح ان هاي وجهه نظر
الجامعه العربيه او اعضاء الجامعه العربيه
ان الوضع القائم لم يكن قابل للاستدامه
وان لا مجال لحل الازمه السوريه الا بحوار
مع الحكومه السوريه وقناعتنا ان
مثل ما ذكر معالي الامين ان مكان سوريا هو
داخل الجامعه ان يكون هذا الحوار حوارا
سليما لاننا نتحاور مع حكومه وهذه الحكومه
لها سيادتها ولابد ان يكون حكما منطقيا
نفهم وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده وشركائنا
في الغرب لكن لمعالجه التحديات القائمه
لابد ان نجد مقاربه جديده وهذه لن تاتي
الا بالحوار وبالتاكيد سوف نتحاور مع
شركائنا في اوروبا وفي امريكا
لمعالجه
لنقول مصادر القلق وهناك
في المقام الاول ازمه انسانيه الان هناك
لاجئين سوريين يريدون ان يريدون لبلدهم
لابد ان نساعدهم لايجاد السبيل العوده
هناك وضع اقتصادي صعب في سوريا كل هذا
نتيجه للوضع القائم الوضع القائم ضرره على
المواطن السوري قبل اي احد اخر لذلك نحن
مهتمون بايجاد حلول عمليه واقعيه
هذه لم تتم الا بالتعاون والشراكه مع
الحكومه في دمشق
سمحتم لنا اصحاب السمو المعالي بسؤال
الاخير
قناه
فكيف تخططون
هنالك عقوبات وهل تدفعون لرفع العقوبات
دون ان
اجتمعات
من روسيا
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الاوروبي
في دوله عربيه في مقر جامعه الدول العربيه
في القاهره
المضيفه هو جامعه الدول العربيه
ولن ينعقد في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي بروكسل
على السؤال التي طرح عفوا
بيننا وبين الغرب ونحن جميعا مهتمون
بامكانيه عوده العجينه السوري بامان الى
منازل مواطن وسنعمل مع حكومه دمشق لتحقيق
ذلك
سيعملون معنا لتحقيق ذلك سنعمل
ضمن قراري مجلس الامن
وفي تلك القرارات وهنالك سوف نعمل على
مشاريع التعاون بكر
حيث امكن ولكن اهم شيء هو مصلحه الشعب
السوري
والتقريب ان هذه متشدده لا تصب مصلحه
الشعب السوري لذلك ستكون مقارنه هذا
الحوار بهذا الاطار
نعطي السؤال هنا قناه الشرق
الاوسط طيب رامي بعدها بس يكون مختصر
حتى نترك فرصه للزملاء في اليمين
قد يكون الامين العام لا يستطيع ان يبقى
معايا القاهره حرحب به
سمو الامير عبدالله الزبيدي قناه الشرق
والنبي انت عامله يعني
الحديث الان هو عن مسار خطوه بخطوه احنا
استمعنا للمسؤولين السوريين في هذه القمه
كان الحديث بشكل خاص عن قضيه الدعم
الاقتصادي عن اعاده اعاده الاعمار هل هذا
سيسبق التسويه السياسيه قضيه عوده
اللاجئين
شكرا لن يسبق شيء شيء يعني هي خطوه بخطوه
كما ذكرتها يعني وهذا حتى نهج يتبناه
الاخوه في دمشق ومنفتحون على ايجاد حلول
في هذا الاطار فهي خطوه مقابل خطوه
كلنا ننتهي الان
شكرا لكم اصحاب السمو المعالي شكرا شكرا
لكم
والشكر لكم على حضوركم الى المؤتمر شكرا
جزيلا والى اللقاء قريب باذن الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات